I think the main thing in the comics of
course can do in this day and age is get
people to be a little more flexible a
little more thoughtful about decisions
they make and seeing both sides the
problem today on the podcast seeing
economics in a whole new light of an
application the course about the
maintenance apply about Kim Kardashian
tweeting herself out it picture an
exercise corset and that increased
demand for exercise corsets and so
thinking about how something where
students can see and say wow I hadn't
realized that economics helped me think
about that problem
welcome to choc radio a podcast about
inspired teaching at MIT
I'm your host Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare in this episode we'll be
talking about the course 1401
introductory microeconomics this course
is filled with unique and creative
applications for microeconomics in our
everyday lives
I'll be chatting today with the creator
of this course professor John Gruber one
of the things I was most excited to find
out was the way people perceive
economics so I asked professor Gruber
what misconceptions students tend to
bring to this class that's a good
question I think they tend to perceive
it as maybe softer than it is
maybe not perceived that you're gonna
derive fairly sharp tools they're gonna
help you explain a lot of the world
fairly easily then on the other hand
they often come sort of with
expectations that will explain more of
the world than we can so how do you help
them address these misconceptions I
think by just being honest about the
limitations and benefits of our models
by explaining the power that our models
can deliver in fairly simple terms and
explaining a lot of the world but at the
same time representing the things the
models can't easily explain and being
honest about that and trying to get
students interested in studying more
economics that can explain those things
as well I don't expect most viewers of
my videos to go on and get a PhD in
economics unfortunately I expect they're
gonna go out and have other jobs do
other things and I want them to be more
educated consumers of news and to
understand what's going on in the world
in terms of economic policy could we
talk a minute about the real-world
applications it's a really interesting
part of the course you have LeBron James
it's College decision
or surge pricing tell us about your
decision to really anchor the course
with these real-world applications it's
what makes economics fun I mean once
again I'm not training people to be
comics PhDs here I'm training people to
think like an economist if thinking like
an economist if you've got a very facile
mind and you sort of look at the basic
theory videos I teach you you can
understand it but you only really
understand something when you go out in
the real world and apply it and so it's
a chance for people to see the ways that
economics rules the world but to also
sort of apply what they learned to make
sure they understand it what tips for
educators do you have about selecting
really good applications I think it's
just a matter of trying to find examples
in the real world that are relatable
students that are companies they've
heard of and issues they think about and
that in a not necessarily obvious way
teach you about the lessons you want to
learn you know have an application the
course about domain and supply about Kim
Kardashian tweeting herself out a
picture of exercise corset and that
increased demand for exercise corsets
and so thinking about how something
where students can see it and say wow I
hadn't realized that you can onyx helps
me think about that problem
professor Gruber's passion for economics
is clear and I wanted to get to the
bottom of it why does he care so much
about helping others find their passion
for economics and how did his own
curiosity begin I came to MIT knowing
that I was good at math but I didn't
really like it what I liked was
real-world Social Policy types of issues
and I took 1401 and said oh my god I can
use math to find the real world isn't
this cool and I've been sort of hooked
ever since many of your listeners will
not realize that there was a time when
we used to talk to people next to us on
a plane before we had smartphones and
every time I fly in a plane and tell the
person next to us an economics professor
they'd say oh that was the worst course
I ever took and I thought that can't be
true
I mean it might not be the best but
there's no way could be the worst COSO
ever took I realized it's just was
generally badly taught in our school
systems and so I was always interested
in trying to address that but I think
really what I really want to go is
figuring out a way to write better
problems it's easy to write a problem
with a mathematical solution you know
the firm has the following production
function solved for their profit
maximization
it's harder to bright problems that
involve math but also derive intuition
and that's really want to go is help
students bridge that link between
solving an equation understanding why
they're doing it and what they're
learning from it
I just want to talk about that a little
bit more because you're not the first
MIT faculty member to really want to
hone in on intuition and I'm just
wondering like how do we develop
students intuition cuz I'm sure
educators out there in all sorts of
fields are wanting to do this too is it
something that's developed over time in
a field and just with experience or is
it something we can cultivate as
teachers I think that it is something we
can cultivate I think that it comes from
not assuming people know things they
don't know it comes from teaching in
layers so that if there's a set of
things I teach that I'd be really
disappointed if not everyone came out
with the intuition for my class there's
others more subtle concepts that if not
everyone remembers them or understands
them then that's not the end of the
world but I'd like students who want to
go on to be like oh that's interesting I
want to go down that path so I think
it's really about getting the things
that are really you really want people
to know hammering them but the other
thing I like that in my class is really
always have a constant road map I always
tell the students okay here's where he
came from here's we're going here's
where it fits in so they can sort of a
have a list extensive how it all fits
together
in our conversation I asked professor
Gruber what he believes educators can do
practically to transfer problems from
the classroom into the real world and
his answer touched on a point that is
coming into play all over our modern
world the complexity and truth about
well truth I think the main number one
thing is just to teach a healthy respect
for the scientific method to teach
students that there are objective truths
and that there's this long staying
scientific method for how we get at them
the other thing however is to recognize
that there are two sides of almost every
issue and that this is something that a
lot of students at MIT sometimes have
problems with my class which is it's not
just an equation with run right answer
there's pros and cons to a lot of these
things so I think it's teaching a search
for the objective truth that can help
you come to the conclusion that works
for you that there's not a one right
answer you and I might disagree about a
topic but we should agree an objective
set of facts and have a scientific
method for getting to our conclusion I
think that's the key in the today's
world especially that's the key is just
getting people to have a healthy
disagreement rather than on hopefully
disagreement
one of the most compelling parts of this
course is how it emphasizes ways to
carry its concepts forward into the real
world students are given specific
pathways they might follow in their
career or lives outside of school where
they can use these concepts this was
something really important to Professor
Gruber and I wanted to know why I feel
that economics is enormous ly powerful
I'm what you might call an imperialistic
economist I feel like economics can
explain lots of things in the world and
there's very few situations where a good
economic framework can't help you at
least go forward and thinking about it
and I don't want students to just take
the AP test and forget about it quite
frankly I want this to be something they
bring with them and actually keep with
them you know it's a famous old side of
Night Live skit about what you remember
five years after college and it's five
minutes and three 1/2 minutes of it's
spring break I want them to try to have
a basic set of intuitions that they can
understand can apply to decisions
they're gonna make about how much to
save in their 401 K to how hard to work
to what car to choose to how to buy a
house at cetera and quite frankly to me
personally to how to vote and think
about public policy a set of tools that
they can bring to bear on thinking about
these important problems in America
today one slight difficulty we have is a
lot of students come in much to
determine and set in their ways and what
they're going to do I'm going to be an
engineer I'm gonna be a computer
scientist and they're often not flexible
enough so part of Ivy my job a lot of
times when they're taking economics that
is taken because they have to and my job
is to get them to say hey actually like
this and I love nothing more when I get
an email from a student saying wow I
wasn't even going to study economics but
I like your course that I want to major
in economics that was wonderful but I
also want the students is not gonna
major economics to several years later
saying hey yeah that's something I can
relate what I learned in economics how I
think about that problem and that could
help me in my life
microeconomics is basically colonics
macroeconomics essentially applied micro
it's basically it's about everything
every decision we make every decision
firms make can all be informed by
economic framework and they can be
formed in a particularly healthy way
today because the economic framework
really is about trade-offs and about
thinking the fact that nothing's easy
everything involves pros and cons and
trade-offs and their shades of grey to
every decision we make and I think the
main thing in economics course can do in
this day and age is get people to be a
little more flexible a little more
thoughtful about decisions they make and
single sides the problem if you're
interested in learning more about
microeconomics or viewing his real-world
application videos you can visit
professor Gruber's interactive online
mitx course on EDX to access his full
lecture videos from his on campus
teaching head over to a scholar course
on our site at ocw.mit.edu you'll also
find 20 plus additional courses just on
microeconomics on OCW if you're an
instructor head on over to the OCW
educator portal at ocw.mit.edu slash
educator to find resources just for you
thanks for listening until next time I'm
Sarah Hansen from MIT OpenCourseWare
[Music]